on l'attendait un peu plus tôt le
samsung galaxy s 21 et feu il est arrivé
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle alors le
galaxy s 21 f j'ai pu le prendre en main
quelques jours avant noël sous embargo
tranquille pépère épouse je peux vous
dire enfin ce que j'en pense alors gardé
de présenter aujourd'hui officialisée en
tout cas aujourd'hui on se le testera
d'ici quelques semaines donc si vous
n'êtes pas encore abonné venez vous
abonner comme ça vous serez tous je vous
montrerai tout la partie photo vidéo et
compagnie parce que c'est le point qui
est super intéressant pourquoi parce que
souvenez vous on était en septembre 2020
samsung lancée pour la première fois un
modèle fans edition et feurs le galaxy s
20 je pense que le produit vous aura pas
échappé et c'était vachement intéressant
pourquoi parce que ça nous montrait
vraiment que samsung élargit ses sa
gamme est ce parce que la gamme sc la
gamme photo vidéo performance c'est à
dire qu'on va avoir une espèce de mix
entre ce qu'est le smartphone plus haut
de gamme quasiment parfait c'est samsung
en termes de photos en terme de vidéo
sont les usages principaux alors la
vidéo rattrape doucement la photo mais
on y est en tout cas pas ce cas beaucoup
de vidéos ma petite toque les réseaux
des compagnies bref passons bien
évidemment un très bel écran bien
évidemment de la performance derrière
pour pouvoir avoir du multimédia pour
pouvoir avoir bien évidemment du king
donc ça c'est un deuxième smartphone
dans cette gamme et feu samsung galaxy s
21 il falloir ce qui est super
intéressant s'il voit est-ce que ce
modèle est réussi est ce qu'il est
intéressant comment est-ce qu'il vient
se positionner dans la gamme je trouve
qu'il arrive un peu tard mais je vais
vous expliquer tout ça mais juste après
ce petit générique
ok on y trouve qu'il arrive un peu tôt
pourquoi je vous le disais le samsung
galaxy s 20 et feu est arrivé en
septembre 2020 car dans les deux cas ce
que le samsung galaxy s 21 et feu arrive
en septembre 2021 ça paraissait logique
tant par rapport à l'appellation s-21 ça
suit les années aujourd'hui en 2021 le s
21 en 2022 on aura le f-22 vous l'avez
dans le bide grave donc là ça veut dire
qu'on est au mois de janvier 2022 es21
va sortir probablement au mois de
février donc on a un produit s 21 qui
sont en 2022 suivent un petit peu le
truc pourtant causé un petit peu tard en
terme de timing néanmoins le produit
reste intéressant parce que il vient se
trouver une position vachement bien dans
la gamme alors avant de vous donner tous
les détails de la fiche technique et
vous dire qu'est ce qu'il est capable de
faire sur le papier et bien on va aussi
devoir un peu à quoi ressemble en termes
de look alors le tout numéro un c'est
que la prise en main je trouve plutôt
vraiment bien il a une très très bonne
prise en main je trouve très léger donc
s'associer un poids qui est extrêmement
positif sur ce smartphone on a4 couleur
olive la vente noir et blanc c'est sûr
que c'est le modèle noir qu'ils
donneraient plus c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que si vous avez des
galaxies buzz deux pédales pouvez venir
les assortir prenez le noir avec le noir
les olives avec les olives les rôles
avant de rafler compris un peu
l'histoire et au delà de ça est ce qui
fait la force de ce produit c'est
l'écosystème derrière alors on en
reparlera probablement que l'écosystème
de samsung mais je pas si vous
connaissez bien l'écosystème samsung
vous prenez vos smartphones samsung vous
prenez votre application smart 6 alors
que martin on peut la voir sur des
smartphones que des smartphones de
samsung mais c'est quand même mieux de
tout optimisé avec les smartphones
samsung vous le faites communiquer
facilement avec votre tablette avec un
pc de samsung ils vont arriver en france
un bientôt il va arriver fin 2020 ils
arriveront 2022 les pc de samsung ou
technique avec votre lave-linge votre
réfrigérateur bref l'écosystème samsung
c'est pratique et ça marche bien ça bout
l'idée de venir choisir son smartphone
au centre et ensuite tous les produits
éco système on viendra plus tard dessus
qu'est ce qu'on voit sur ce smartphone
est bien qu on a à peu près la même idée
que ce qu'on avait avec le samsung
galaxy s 20 effet on a toujours un bel
écran amoled
on a une diagonale de 6,4 pouces on
avait un 6,5 pouces sur le s20 il fait
donc légèrement plus petit on est quand
même plus grand que le s 21 qui est à
6,2 pouces la différence vous avec les
autres modèles de la gamme s 21 c'est
que vous êtes sur un écran dynamique
amoled 2 x ici on est sur du super
amoled donc on aura qui a été décrit un
petit peu moins haut de gamme on reste
quand même dans le haut de gamme avec le
super amoled s'échouer à chouïa mais de
l'autre côté on se rend bien compte que
le privait de plus bas mais ça on ya
maintenant quelques instants il ya un
truc qui est intéressant à savoir c'est
qu'ici on a un taux de rafraîchissement
120 hertz tout ça c'est plutôt cool pour
le gaming et pour toute expérience
multimédia ou que vous allez venir
scrollé ok ça porte vachement de
fluidité c'est vraiment l'idée du 120
hertz sans d'ailleurs que si vous savez
pas c'est le nom est-ce que vous avez
par seconde dans une seconde vous avez
120 images pour s'être beaucoup plus
fluide que si vous avez 60 images en une
seconde sur du 60 hertz un peu classique
sauf qu'ici il est non adaptés tiff ça
veut donc dire que votre 120 hertz et
bien ça sera soit tout le temps du sang
verts surgelés descendre en 60 heures tu
n'as pas le faire automatiquement donc
si vous restez tout le temps on s'en va
ailleurs si vous admire consommer un peu
plus au niveau de votre batterie
l'autonomie qui sera un petit peu
moindre donc il vouera pense à venir
faire le switch vous même si vous vous
rendez compte que vous en ai pas votre
smartphone hostilement que vous
souhaiteriez au niveau de la batterie
parce que vous avez fini de jouer vous
switchez engrand 60 hertz bon voilà ça
c'est du point de détail mais sa voix et
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalise
en partenariat avec reno schyle parce
qu'avoir un beau smartphone c'est
chouette il faut venir le protégé alors
chez rhinochill vous avez énormément
protection vous avez des coques des
protections d'écran vous avez des bumper
vous avez plein de choses des cordons
des caps on avait tous les côtés et on a
également ici de nouveaux produits qui
viennent d'arriver pour le samsung
galaxy s 21 et feurs regardez c'est
écrit noir sur blanc s 21 il faut que je
passe et vous le voyez bien regarder on
se rapproche ses écrits si samsung
galaxy s 21 il faut alors vous avez deux
produits ce que je vais vous montrer
vous allez voir un peuple là on va voir
ce petit noir qui est vachement sympa
comme ça et on va avoir ici on regarde
un effet carbone donc là c'est un peu
classique ses standards mais c'est très
bien ça revient le protégez vous laisser
résistance bleue mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là parce que chez rhinochill vous avez
plein de collections différentes
regardez on va me revoir ici au niveau
des produits vous avez une nouvelle
collaboration chez rhino chine notamment
ici avec star wars mandaloriennes ne
pouvant venir mettre votre coque aux
couleurs deux mandats lauriane et ça
c'est vachement vous regardez c'est
hyper classe j'adore celle là super
héros quand vous avez également disney
classics avec lilo et stitch les 101
dalmatiens bambi le roi lion la belle et
le clochard j'en passe et des meilleurs
regardez c'est super cool si vous êtes
fan de l'univers disney vous trouverez
votre bonheur ici vous en avez d'autres
ici sur l'univers de attaque aux titans
est également de dragon ball ça c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal bon vous en
avez plein d'autres vous avez van gogh
museum à revel one piece france rugby
batman et vous avez des tonnes de co lab
et avec le code re 22 grrr 22 vous
bénéficiez d'au moins 5% de remise
fournir protéger votre smartphone
acheter vocable vos protections d'écran
vaughn peur et compagnie donc ça c'est
vachement bien profitez-en si vous
voulez acheter le samsung galaxy s 21 et
fuck ans et à venir prendre doctrinaux
chine parce que si j'aime les petites
déconvenues au moins vous êtes protégé
et ça c'est cool puisque on se parle de
multimédia on va se parler forcément
d'odieux on voit qu'on a un écran de
qualité en tout cas sur le papier
qu'elle est super intéressant mais
connaissant le boulot de samsø j'en
doute absolument pas maintenant on va
regarder ce qui se passe du côté de
l'audio on va avoir des haut parleurs
stéréo me rajouter un peu en
spécialisation alors ce que j'imagine
donc je me doutais je vais avoir un haut
parleur droit qui va être principal qui
ont envoyé un peu son pays en parlant de
renforts sur le côté on a une expérience
avec du dolby atmos bien évidemment ici
on a du bluetooth pour me rappellerai
ses galaxy 2 2 on s'en doutera à voir
maintenant ce que ça rendra lors des
phases de test qui arriveront un peu
plus tard donc une fois de plus venez
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et il ya un autre qui est intéressant
c'est pas tant au niveau l'expérience
audio c'est au niveau de la performance
puisque vous savez qu'en termes d'usagés
revenus ce qui est extrêmement important
et bien cette gaming pour pouvoir avoir
du gaming et bien c'est elle vous faut
et bien c'est de la performance derrière
c'est intéressant parce que si on
regarde ce qu'ils ont fait son galaxy s
20 et feu on avait un exil hausse 990 là
on est plus mac leur propre processeur
exynos on est passé chez qualcomm sur un
snapdragon 888 qui est le processeur le
plus performant de l'année 2021 autre
côté ça paraît assez logique samsung
galaxy je suis traité 1 et feu 2021
dragon 888 ça fonctionnera alors on
pourrait se dire ok c'est un peu ballot
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas atteint
brian 8 jian wang qui était présentée
fin 2021 qui va être le processeur de
smartphone le plus puissant pour l'année
2022 pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi alors ça
me paraît aussi logique en terme de
cours isaac pas là dessus ils vont
chercher à mettre sur le s 22 l'eure
exynos qui sera pour eux le plus
performant donc pourquoi venir mettre sa
dragonne huit jeunes moines ça
fonctionnerait pas trop d'un autre côté
soyez tranquilles eux c'est un dragon
888 il est vachement performante marche
très bien c'est un processeur 5g les
très rapides très performant on peut
faire tourner tous les jeux du
playstation aucun problème pour tout ce
qui va être usage gaming sans problème
usages multimédias ça ira bien avoir la
spécialisation ça on le verra lors du
test à savoir qu'ici vous avez le choix
entre 6 ou 8 giga drain stockage c'est
soit 128 soit 256 giga de stockage et
puis on verra on verra lancé que la
question que je leur ai posée lorsqu'on
ses rencontres avec samsung et je le
redis ça un peu ballot sur un smartphone
qui est quand même positionné dans le am
ne pas avoir ce fameux sa dragonne 8
jane one alors qu'on va retrouver en
2022 les smartphones à peu près au même
prix et qui ont un sens dragonne 8 genua
bon je me dis que la force de samsung
sait que samsung s samsung la marque
fait vendre énormément que tout le monde
n'est pas technophiles et tout le monde
a pas se poser la question du sens
dragon 1188 versus le 8 juin c'est ça
qui fera un peu la différence en tout
cas le produit comme les lie d'ailleurs
plutôt intéressant alors y'a des trucs à
voir aux plates formes afin que j'ai
pris mais ben oui j'ai des notes vont
montrer que ça aura peut être que je
vais vous dire je peux tout appris par
coeur on a ici une batterie quatre mille
cinq cents millions paire d'heures c'est
la même chose qu'on avait l'année
dernière ici on n'a pas de blog de
charges incluent qu ce qui est
aujourd'hui un peu classiques et
notamment dans la gamme s 21 alors on
peut avoir de la charge 25 croate rapide
et de la recharge sans fil 15 matches
voilà ça faut le savoir on tourne du
point de vue logiciel sur when you 4.0
basé sur l'android où ça on en reparlera
un peu plus tard et puis au niveau de la
photo on a trois capteurs on a
effectivement ce triptyque qui me paraît
normal est intéressant aujourd'hui sur
les smartphones haut de gamme grand
angle ultra grand-angle tel objectif
grand-angle ultra-grand-angle on a deux
capteur 12 mégapixels sans grand angle
d'un capteur dualpix elle plutôt pas mal
et au niveau de vote et l'objectif on à
zoom optique x 3 et 11 h 15 au numérique
soit 39 à 30 on connaît un peu
l'histoire on n'y va pas ça va pas être
terrible mais il faut à troyes il faut
voir on regardera ça bien évidemment
lors du test une caméra de salfit 30 2
mégapixels un peu vient filmer chez en
4k uhd à 60 images par secondes après ça
il y appelle fonctionne est intéressante
il ya single take et compagnie mais tout
ça on le verra bien évidemment lorsqu'on
testera sa smart que je trouve complet
il a tout ce qu'il faut en terme de
photos pour réussir en tout cas sur le
papier ces photos en plus il est
certifié ip 68 résistants à l'eau et à
la poussière et la radio wifi 6 du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé ce soit
samsung paix que ce soit google paie et
il ya un truc qui est vachement
intéressant c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
au niveau du prix puisque c'est un
produit qui est proposé en 628 à 759
euros et à 8 256 à 829 euros alors
regardez c'est là que ça devient
intéressant et je mets tout de suite du
4 janvier au 8 février vous avez vos
galaxie buzz deux offerts il coûte 149
euros donc en gros ils vous offrent 149
a été pas mal non plus que ces galaxies
buzz deux formes achement intéressant
alors regarde ce que je vous montre vaut
pour le moment je suis en train de
tourner je suis en train de tourner
cette vidéo on est fin décembre 2021
j'imagine qu'à l'annnonce de ce produit
à l'officialisation et tarifs peuvent un
peu bouger se bousculent et je voulais
quand même voulu montrer ça me
paraissait être vraiment intéressant et
pertinent alors regarder sur le site de
samsung samsung fr le galaxy s 21 5 j'ai
donc le smartphone qui était présentée
début 2021 on est sur une config 828 ici
on est sûrs en 628 donc sur 1 828 sur le
s 21 on est au tarif de produits non bon
il n'affiche pas là mais c'est un
produit qui coûte 859 euros ça veut dire
qu'il est 100 euros plus cher que le s
21 et feu c'est à dire que le s 21 on
aura un processeur qui sera un peu moins
performant que le cndd ragone 888 cas
présent sur le s 21 est fait néanmoins
on ira un peu plus loin en termes de
photos en leur indiquant qu'il sera un
peu de meilleure qualité donc c'est vrai
que si ce s-21 moment du lancement du
s21 et feu reste à 859 à 100 euros près
la question se pose en termes de qualité
d'écran en termes de performance à
savoir s'il faut aller sur le s 21 un
effet aussi folie sur le laisse bien
évidemment et tarifs risquent de bouger
moins de l'annnonce de ce produit un
autre cas voir et qui est aussi
intéressant c'est sur le s20 f toujours
au moment de l' annonce le s20 et feu
hop là il présente les buzz dans ces
passages monfils le s20 et feu toujours
pareil à fin décembre laisse 20 ans et
feu n'a pas été officialisé et bien
voyez sur la version 5 5 avril vers son
cadet 5 g ici il ya qu une version 5 g
sur le s 21 et feront 128 on l'était à
759 mais ils ont fait une promo à 599
donc les tarifs sont susceptibles de
bouger il va falloir avoir bien
évidemment ce qui va arriver en début
d'année 2022 quand le f-22 va sortir
parce que j'imagine que les tarifs du
s21 et fécond probablement descendre
doucement donc pour l'instant en version
828 à 759 euros ça reste un bon
smartphone mais je trouverais beaucoup
plus alléchant si on veut gagner encore
un petit peu en termes de prix bien
évidemment ça arrivera au mois de
février et encore plus au mois de mars
les tarifs vont bouger quoi qu'il en
soit elle qu'il est là tel qu'il est
présenté je trouve intéressant je trouve
intéressant parce que compact parce que
performant lorsque polyvalent en termes
de photos vous avez vraiment sa dragonne
888 qui est extrêmement important donc
on a un ensemble complet et cohérent
pour avoir un bon smartphone à 759 euros
le tarif est correct mais dans quelques
mois il va continuer à baisser et sera
encore luz alléchant donc je trouve que
l'on se taise bientôt laissez moi un
petit peu de temps le temps je le
récupère que de tester vous ferez une
vidéo texte on sera le test complet la
photo la vidéo on va tout régler tous
les côtés ça s'arrête intéressant se
retrouve bientôt ici là prenez soin de
vous embrasser et à très bientôt les
bizots chaos
[Musique]